bamboozled he was bamboozled
basically it's what happened right and
people got super mad at the man
for leaving her or getting upset at her
but in my mind
yeah we could talk about love or
whatever what not but what's love
what you base your attraction and what's
important to you in a relationship is
your standard yeah it's different for
everybody and like you can't
like the guys who are going to be salty
listening to this are the ones who are
insecure about like not having enough
money
or like you know to impress girls or not
but like
it's just like in five four three
two one what's up everybody welcome to
another episode of the genius brain
podcast
if you haven't heard of this podcast
before it's better than any other
podcast you've ever heard in your life
that's right that's right cheers cheers
we have
uh if you guys have not uh heard a
previous podcast with this girl in it
she told one of the funniest hook-up
stories i've ever heard in my life with
a dude rubbing his nipples all day baby
let's go freesia park everybody what's
up
thank you for having me back she is now
uh officially
an la resident you moved to la i know i
pulled the trigger finally
you know what she's actually been going
back and forth from new york to la for
quite a while and i feel like a lot of
people
always say they're gonna make a move but
they never do right
so why'd you do it well i never like i
always follow through with what i say
so no i really truly do oh god
i know you like dead if i say it then
i'm like really
truly considering it it's just a matter
of when uh but i think back then
just timing wasn't right because
uh back then i was also like super heavy
into the nine to five live i was working
in the beauty industry
um and the main hub if you guys know
like
it's it's in new york city that's where
all the main corporate offices are for
the parent companies
so i was like this is where i need to be
this is where my network is and if i
want to grow in my career
um so it just didn't make sense for me
to move out here to the west coast
where like i don't have opportunity for
growth career-wise because yeah
at the time that was my goal now now
things are a little different
oh she's a youtuber now dude he's really
making [ __ ] youtube content
she'd be getting like 100k views on her
videos that's the wildest thing so if
you guys don't know
i met frieza years ago when she was a
college student
and lightweight she was doing these
vlogs right and at the time
for people who were creating vlog
content her stuff looks like what people
make
now and so for me like i was looking at
the stuff i'm like yo this stuff looks
[ __ ] great for somebody who's doing
it very casually it has no intent
to really push their content out to to
the public to see
and i remember just drunk as [ __ ]
sitting on this like that was like
you you should do youtube like you'll be
so
[ __ ] successful i'm trying to [ __ ]
father this child i'm like just do it
like you you can do something that other
people don't have
and then she's like nah i can't i can't
do it okay
do me i come and do it and now look at
you dude i know
you're [ __ ] killing it it's so random
i well
i don't think it's that random i think
it was like a very gradual
thing that happened as naturally as
possible
um because back then i was 19 at the
time
um just graduating or no i wasn't
graduating i was actually
going between schools transferring like
figuring out
what i really wanted to do with my life
and
youtube was never like something i
considered
i was like you i know that like it was
like kind of far-fetched it's like
something that like
michelle phan or someone like big i was
like i could never beat michelle fawn
like this is not gonna be a thing for me
so
like why am i gonna waste my time
pursuing it i also didn't understand the
logistics behind youtube and i didn't
understand like how you could possibly
make money off of it because at 19 years
old like i don't know i don't know
jack [ __ ] you know so so are you more
calculated then
i'm i'm very safety driven i need
i need to be guaranteed
success and income because that is you
know we were talking about this earlier
like what really drives me in life is
just i need to be comfortable and set
financially
just because i never had that growing up
so
that in whatever decisions i made i was
like
this has to make me somewhat like secure
financially it's interesting because we
were talking about
when we have a conversation we're
talking about what really
i you know we talked about before we
talk about pillars right like who what
are these pillars in your life that you
need from your partner right these are
like stuff that can't be moved it's a
foundation
and for her she found out that having
somebody who's stable that makes a good
income
is very important to her because i threw
it out i was like what if this dude was
like an elementary school teacher she's
like
nah [ __ ] education and [ __ ] kids are
so bad you know that sounds
so bad but it's true it's kind of
so it's not that i have anything against
like teachers or whatnot it's just i
know
exactly what i want i know the lifestyle
i want to live i just know teacher's
salary won't get me there and as
i know a lot of guys are gonna be like
salty listening to this they're gonna be
like yo like [ __ ] this girl she's so
superficial but no like i have
i know what i want like i have standards
of like
the lifestyle i want to live and it's
nowhere like i don't want to be
where i was when i was younger because i
was like broke as [ __ ]
yeah so like i don't want to be there
anymore and like i don't want to
struggle for money and like i want
i myself want to make a lot of money
it's not like i want a sugar daddy
i want to make a lot of money and i want
someone to be
there with me equally or more okay how
about this let me give you a scenario
yeah
all right so there's a do that you meet
right yeah
physically what do you wanted a guy okay
what does he look like
describe him i don't i don't really go
for looks
i know i know i can find him i know this
about you but we all have a
want of what like for me i'm not a big
looks guy either right
like yeah but i lust after women yeah i
would like a girl with a fat ass nice
tits and a thin waist whatever what not
right
so for you let's let's let's paint this
picture right his name what's his name
his name is juan delgado yeah fun one
what juan has a really nice haircut got
a nice haircut guys
yeah fade uh vince the barber cuts him
up every week he's dressed
nicely but but that to me is like very
clean basic but nicely fitting
pieces fashion basics on point uh
what else what's his what's his what's
his body type look like
he's he goes to the gym he works out
he's not like
ripped and shredded but he's got some
bulk you got he got a little muscles to
him he's got a little biceps a little
tricephals
yes right he got a little chesticles
going on right he ain't got those skinny
ass legs he got a couple of calf muscles
on him
okay this dude personality like what is
he like
um he's goofy goofy like to laugh
like silly doesn't take himself doesn't
take himself too seriously
okay uh he's making good money
okay okay now let's go check it out all
this stuff is checked off
but and we're gonna i'm gonna base off a
salary off of elliot what it costs to
live here right
but he makes 70k a year
he has all the stuff checked off is he a
yes or no well it depends it's not that
black and white it's like
then what are you doing to achieve your
goals are your goals bigger because if
you're comfortable with 70k that doesn't
work for me he's comfortable with 70k
but he's out here [ __ ] saving babies
out in asia africa and india
that's a deal breaker baby
yeah because it doesn't align with but
the lifestyle that i want to live
i mean that's beautiful that's amazing
that you're saving babies and whatnot
but like
it's different from me you're probably
like better off than i am but that's
just different from what i want
i like that well this this is the weird
thing right because when some people
hear this type of stuff like this is no
judgment based
this is not me passing judgment it's
just me getting an idea of what somebody
really wants right because you want to
put these obstacles in people's places
to see what they really like
everybody's different so sometimes when
here's here's a great example right
years ago there was this photo that was
passed around of
a a man and a woman who got married
right this woman in asian standards cut
up very beautiful you see this family
photo
they have kids kids look a little wonky
right just physically
and so what he found out and i'm not
sure if this was a true story or not but
you know this photo right
found out that she had plastic surgery
so they kind of looked like her private
plastic surgery
husband got mad they divorced got fight
or whatever
right and people are like well [ __ ] this
guy dude that's not real love that's
whatever
i actually got a little heat because i
actually defended him right yeah and the
reason why i defended him was this
he knew what he wanted in a partner
right but
what was important to him was having a
trophy wife this is what he signed up
for
we are not here to judge somebody based
on what our definition of what
attraction and love and what qualifiers
are for somebody else
the point is she lied and he
got something that he didn't sign up for
he was bamboozled
he was bamboozled basically is what
happened right
and people got super mad at the man for
leaving her or getting upset at her
but in my mind yeah we could talk about
love or whatever what not
but what's love what you base your
attraction and what's important to you
in a relationship
is your stance yeah it's different for
everybody and like
you can't like the guys who are going to
be salty listening to this are the ones
who are insecure about like not having
enough money
or like you know to impress girls or not
but like
it's just like that how being
financially stable to me
is just like a must for like a guy let's
say who
who he wants like a driven female like
if a guy's like i want the female to be
ambitious and have goals that's the same
[ __ ]
yeah yeah it's the same [ __ ] i mean
it's hard for people to kind of
because i'm a little different right
like i'm i'm okay with being with a
partner who doesn't make as much money
only because i know that i'll make
enough for both of us
right i think i'm going to be that
person right
but for me like i have a very different
life standard right i don't
i don't need security like that i've
never needed it right i'm somebody who
takes chances and takes risk without
even calculating [ __ ] out like that's
just who i am as a person
that's how i like to live i'm very
comfortable living like that other
people don't i mean for you too like
growing up not growing up with a lot of
money and
not having things that you wanted
probably affected you a lot you know for
me in my case
i didn't grow up with a lot either but
everybody around me was poor
right so when you're around with broke
people broke people just be doing people
things oh yeah that's the thing
i was the only broke person in a rich
neighborhood
that sucks yeah i was always going over
to like my white friends houses with
pools and like
they just i mean they had houses i've
never lived in a house in my entire life
oh really yeah never lived in a house
there's always like rentals or like well
growing up i was living in the basement
of a home
oh [ __ ] yeah so like it was like that
bad
so i'm like do i ever want to go like
i'm kind of like obviously traumatized
as a kid you know like i
i didn't realize that that wasn't normal
until i started going to my friends
houses
these like two point something million
dollar homes you know like middle upper
middle class homes
that's weird it's a comparison game
though because when i when i didn't
realize how poor i was until i went to
college
and then people were just saying [ __ ]
like like to me it's like what rich
people have but that's just what normal
people have yeah
and mind you like growing up we were
probably really poor till i was about 14
and then we were like lower middle class
but when you go to a school like ucr
there's a lot of rich kids that go there
just because they got full rides and it
was close to home
so they were living in they were living
very affluently yeah i didn't know what
that [ __ ] was like
i'm not saying everybody was like that
but when i was
interacting with these people and they
would talk about wealth or what they
would do
i'm like [ __ ] was i poor growing up like
yeah you don't know because poor people
always kick it with poor people yeah and
we kind of just do poor people [ __ ] yeah
you know what i mean like even something
small like
uh me and khalif were talking about this
how
there was somebody who we know that was
freaking out about like small [ __ ] that
we kind of just saw it's like oh my god
there was like a cockroach on the floor
i'm like
yeah it's casual i'm like what about it
they're like oh there's like freaked out
about it i'm like
oh you never grew up broke where did you
just saw [ __ ] like that all the [ __ ]
time
but that's like that's where you get to
see how different people's lives are
i even had a friend too who it's weird
then you start to meet people who do
this weird thing it's like
rich kids that want to act like they're
poor yeah
have you have you met those people yeah
yeah yeah let me tell you something
that [ __ ] irritates the [ __ ] out yeah
it's like like
let me have something yo i can't even be
poor with my poor friends you try to be
poor too [ __ ]
you know yeah so we had a i had a friend
um
this person is very interesting right
because i don't really care how much
money you make i'm
more about like who you are or whatever
right but i think that sometimes they
feel like because they grew up very
affluent and rich
they can't really relate to us but no
none of us really give a [ __ ] about this
stuff we're just chilling
so this person is looking for a home
right
i know what this person does for a
living like
we're kind of kind of in the same space
not really
they're talking about they're looking
for a home and i know what area they're
looking at all these homes minimum 1.5
mil
and i'm like damn dude this house is
expensive how much money this person be
making and so
when they were looking for a house we're
like i was like oh where are you looking
and they told me the neighbor i was like
damn [ __ ] you got it like that
well yeah i've been saving my money
super hard for the past three or four
years i'm like
three for you you didn't save up enough
money for this 1.5 1.2 million dollars
yeah it doesn't add up it doesn't add up
because i know what they do and they
sure as [ __ ] don't make enough money
like they didn't make nowhere near out
what i make and i can't afford that [ __ ]
like a two million dollar home and i'm
like okay
you know i just kind of let it go i'm
like all right all right whatever that's
fine and they're really pressing the
fact that they saved up they work hard
like they know the grind and i'm like
i didn't ask you i just asked you where
you [ __ ] bought your house like where
are you buying your house
i got a little weird so we're talking
and i'm kicking it with one of my other
friends
and i'm like yo did you hear they got
this dope ass house and we're like i was
like congratulating them it's like yo
that's [ __ ] dope
she told me like she worked super hard
for it like yo i'm super proud of her
they're like
her parents bought her that house i was
like wait hold on a second why did you
lie to me
like i never asked i never said anything
like when you told me this whole
spiel about you grinding super hard i
was like wait i was like what did you
just say she goes yeah their
parents bought them that they're like
[ __ ] millionaires like they they put
the down on it and then some they only
had to drop like
like a few grand i'm like why'd you lie
to me
like why did you do that and i think
like their thing was that they wanted to
like either relate or they don't want to
like put us down to show their wealth
like they're grinding out too it's like
listen if your parents made money and
they worked hard to buy you this house
give that to your parents like good on
them why wouldn't you take it like
nobody's judging you because of that
[ __ ]
but in my mind i'm like [ __ ] i can't
even be poor yo let me be poor like try
to take that away from me too like
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] man
that also just goes to show that they're
very aware
of like you know what the consensus
is between like they're quote unquote
not as wealthy friends oh for sure
you know so like they know that like
it's kind of
frowned upon to just be handed
everything in life so they don't want to
like
for me too like i don't even look at it
like that i'm more like you gotta hand
this up because your parents worked hard
yeah why wouldn't you take it take it
my parents would have done the same for
me if they could and they still try till
this day
and we would do that for our kids hell
yeah yeah you know that's what we're
working so hard for you know yeah and i
was like yo this [ __ ] lied to me like
that's all i could think about and now i
want to look at this [ __ ] i'm
like why'd you lie
like i i would have never judged you i
like listen we know your parents are
gajillioners
why do you need to tell me that you
worked hard for this home yeah but also
in that in their defense
there's this like toxic hustle culture
where it's like if you don't
earn your money and do your own [ __ ]
then you're kind of just like a piece of
[ __ ] kind of
mentality muscle culture's a little
weird yeah it's like
as if you're if you're sleeping you're
doing something wrong like
what let me sleep like let me take care
of my mental
[ __ ] health god damn it it's it's
funny though because
i think i like tweeted this not too long
ago where this podcast is brought to you
by word tune you guys already know on
the genius brain podcast we only talk
about sponsors that i actually use and
word tune
has been something that has been saving
my ass specifically when i'm writing
emails
now it doesn't just have to be emails it
could be anything that you're writing in
general
because sometimes you can't find the
right words or you don't even know if
you're writing the right thing in the
right way
well word tune is the first ai powered
writing tool that'll save your ass i
just talked about on this podcast where
i wrote a
business email and the way that i wrote
it was so offensive i actually got into
an argument with one of my partners
well i decided to use wartune after that
and because it helps me rephrase things
in a business manner and there's
actually buttons that you can click
or or options that goes from like casual
speaking to business
and it gives you a whole bunch of
options and a drop down list when you do
it it's freaking amazing
so word tune works anywhere you're
working online google docs slack
outlook web whatsapp and more my
listeners can try wordtune for free
at wardtune.com brain if you're away
from your computer go to wartoon.com
brain on your mobile phone enter your
email and we'll send you a link to make
it easy to get started
get help writing your emails reports
presentations resumes blogs today
go to w-o-r-d-t-u-n-e
dot com slash brain it's it's weird it's
it's a very young person that talks
about like yo if
you fight with me grand and everyday yo
you want to hustling with me bro you
ain't my family
and like it's like always the poorest
people that say that right right right
like bro you broke his [ __ ] and
you know someone's broke and ghetto when
they're saying that [ __ ] rich people
don't say that
yeah richard doesn't say jackson yeah
people who make money they don't want to
say [ __ ] yeah
they just work and they make money and
they they
they do what they do but that grind and
hustle culture is cool like you want to
work hard i agree
like people should work hard you guys
should be active about you know gaining
wealth and
working on these goals but it's weird
when you have to just put it on a
megaphone for everybody else to know
that you're working so much harder than
them
you're over compensating at that point
yeah or something suck my [ __ ] nuts
dude
how about that [ __ ] it's so weird like
i wonder you know what happens is that
everybody wants to talk like a garyvee
without doing what garyvee does right
right because garyvee can talk about
that [ __ ] you know why because garyvee's
like a damn near billionaire right
he could talk that [ __ ] he's a
multi-millionaire or whatever so when he
says that stuff it makes sense
when you have nothing you've done
nothing and you want you want to be the
guru without doing the work that's odd
for me
i hate that [ __ ] dude you want a guy
like that you want a guru guy then that
makes them
make some skrilla i wanna i want a guy
who makes moves in silence
oh really oh he like a fart dude just
bad stinky that was quite as fun
but you're not dating right now no i'm
not i'm honestly like
because right now i youtube is still
very new for me right i mean you know
this
so i'm in just like work mode hustle
mode i still have a full-time job like
i'm just non-stop working and i know
that if i get into i know myself
i know that if i get into a relationship
i'm going to start neglecting priorities
so i'm like yeah sometimes i'm lonely
sometimes i want companionship sometimes
i want validation
but it's not i know logically it's not
the right thing for me right now
so like i don't know i i'm also
not like abstaining very intentionally
either i'm open to whatever happens if
it happens and comes organically
fine like i'm not gonna be like no like
yeah like a vampire with light yeah
like if it if it comes it comes but i'm
not really actively doing anything to
find it either
you're a very confusing person though
right because like
you're you're somebody that i feel when
you're in a relationship you definitely
need
love right however you refuse to give it
no that's just the the the modern but
the camera's still going
like you you refuse to give love but
then at the same time there is a certain
level that you want no here's the thing
i think the way i give love is just
different
like i'm like going back to like the
love language thing i'm totally access
service the way i give
i'm not a i'm not a verbally
affectionate person at all i didn't grow
up with that in my house like i never
learned that
uh physical touch i didn't see that
growing up my parents never like touched
each other they never slept in the same
room
even they're like that's that's not
something i'm like
familiar with or comfortable with i mean
don't get me wrong i'm sounding like
i don't touch my significant other at
all i do but it's not my main form
of showing love the way i show love i'm
100 an acts of service girl like
i will think of your needs before you
even think of it and i'll take care of
it for you
that's the way i show love but not i i
feel like most
guys they also show in acts of love but
acts of service but they don't
receive necessarily that way i feel like
most a lot of guys that i've dealt with
at least
were like words of affirmation or like
physical touch or other things so
a lot of my exes were just i think the
wrong match
for me because like in my head i'm like
i'm doing so much i'm going out of my
way to do so much for you on your behalf
and i'm thinking of you before i think
of myself
like oh if you had a bad day at work i'm
gonna
prepare like dinner for you and i'll do
laundry for you make sure everything's
taken care of so you don't have to think
as soon as you get home you can just
relax do you ever feel like sometimes
that
your effort of doing acts of service
sometimes gets undermined when they
don't when they need the the verbal
affirmation versus the active service
yeah because i mean that's why i
resented
a lot of or not even a lot the most
recent x this is where it was the most
prevalent
the difference in like the way we showed
and gave
um affection i just built a lot of
resentment over time because he wasn't
like that's not that's not his thing axe
is serious like he couldn't he could
care
like less he couldn't care less um
i feel like he was more like a a
communication kind of guy
um he was definitely
someone who just like i don't know i i
he saw what i was doing
but it just like it didn't really matter
to him so i i built a lot of resentment
because i didn't feel appreciated for
doing everything it's hard though right
because and this is a conflict that uh i
i went through a lot because the way
that sometimes we want to give love is
not the way that somebody wants to
receive it right
right so there's a little bit of this
this hard because
i had to figure out what muriel liked
right
i'm a type of person that shows love by
physical touch
i want to hold your hand i'll put my
hand on your back i'll
snuggle you whatever that's how i show
love right or
i'll do acts of service she is [ __ ]
words of affirmation
and i'm not used to that yeah right and
i actually had to learn
to learn how to give love how they want
to receive it versus the way that i want
to receive that's the hardest part about
being in a relationship
yeah that's the hardest part you have to
change the way you are and if like this
person is worth it
then like you're going to have to like
fix your [ __ ] basically
100 yeah and that's i think that's the
biggest reason why people break up
because they don't they're not willing
to do that
yeah you know it's [ __ ] difficult
like like telling somebody a good job
over [ __ ] is something i never grew
up with yeah
same my dad we got into a huge fight i
always i told the story before but
literally i was at wit's ends with my
father right because we had a certain
point in our relationship where he
wanted me to do what he wanted me to do
and he thought that he knew the key to
my happiness
right so did whatever he did did all
this stuff i [ __ ]
aced all my classes and this is when i
was going to community college after i
left the university
and one day i was just like he never
said good job
he never said you're doing great or
whatever and then i looked at my
dad and he was giving me [ __ ] about
everything and i looked at him i was
like bro
i've been doing everything you asked me
to and i've been doing i mean
i'm exceptional at it right i was like
you have never told me
good job once in my life you have never
said that to me i'm 22
23 years old at the time i'm like
whenever you ever told me i'm doing a
good job he goes
what are you talking about i did
yesterday i was like what the [ __ ] you
know you didn't he goes i did this
he tapped me in my butt i was like you
[ __ ] up
you [ __ ] emotionally stunted man dude
that's koreans that's just korean
culture
yeah and but i've been doing it a lot
more it took a while though
you have to practice and be willing to
practice yeah like she'll do like some
basic [ __ ] i'm talking about mario would
just i don't know
let me tell you something this girl got
wrecked one time because you know
i'm the cooker in the house i like
cooking i like food i get super into
that [ __ ]
so this girl makes an abomination of a
burrito like
i'm talking about she was learning how
to wrap a burrito real nice and i
learned how to wrap a burrito from the
homie uh
caesar from avenue 26 tacos and so i i
was like learning how to do it
and so she makes this taco with this
burrito
with like ham cottage cheese and
raspberry jam
and like spinach inside and she goes
this is really good i didn't know what
it was
i bit into it and i spit it out and then
she was like
you don't like it i'm like who would
like this why would you do this to me
right but she was trying to show but she
wanted me to say
good job like in that moment i could
have been like hey you did a good job
wrapping this burrito but this tastes
like a direct [ __ ]
and you fed me that do you hate me like
why did you do this to me
and then her best friend that we were
dying laughing but she needs the verbal
affirmation
and i've seen these moments in her
personal life with her with her own
parents
where sometimes she fiends for it
because she doesn't get it from her
parents
like her parents have never done this to
her they're very critical about her
they're
very korean whatever she does there's
always a [ __ ] comment about it right
oh you did that you could have done it
this way did you do that why didn't you
do it this way
so now when it comes to critiques she
hears her parents
she's like oh there's nothing is ever
good enough so now
i have to go ahead and give her that
verbal affirmation
she folds a piece of paper i'm like
that's the type that's the smoothest
crease
i ain't never seen on a piece of paper
cuz
you know what i mean dude i feel like i
could never be with a
words of affirmation guy like it makes
me want to like
hurl oh okay we we actually joke about
this
because this guy always texts me and be
like say i love you back
i love you [ __ ] i'm like i can't she's
literally gripping her phone like
a [ __ ] cat i can't like i'll i'll
like see her out in new york when she
was there and before i leave i'm like
hey
i love you and she just goes get the
[ __ ] away
okay bye okay bye like i've known you
now for [ __ ] hello years dude
i just do it and i'm like this is gonna
be the day that she says it back to me
i love you and then she goes stop
stop you're making me feel weird so [ __ ]
your mom doesn't say i love you to you
she does i'm more like my dad my dad
doesn't ever say it
oh well you could say it to your mom
though no i i can't
get the [ __ ] out of here you're [ __ ]
lying to me right now i swear to god
i've never said i love you it's a
running joke now
between our phone calls she'll at the
end of a phone call she'll be like
oh okay i love you okay bye oh my god
she'll be she'll
she'll say i love you too to herself and
then she'll be like she'll hang up and
we just both laugh and then
you'll never you'll never say i love you
to your mom maybe when i'm older and
like
get a little bit more emotionally mature
and go through some therapy maybe but
it's that hard for you to say i love you
yeah it's like pulling teeth
i brought it up to my like i did better
help like three times
but i think the therapist wasn't a good
fit for me
uh but i did bring it up she i mean she
didn't really
give me really much insight or help me
figure out
maybe like i already knew where it was
coming from it's like my childhood
yeah like it's where my mom never really
said i love you a lot until
maybe a few years ago and it kind of
threw me off she goes okay i love you
other and i'm like
who the [ __ ] is this you never said i
love you to me like she gave me kisses
and hugs
never said i love you though out of
nowhere she started saying i love you
and even now when i say it to her it
literally feels like my teeth are
falling out or something it feels weird
but you do it anyways i do it
because i know that number one i think
it would hurt her if i didn't say it
and i feel like it makes her happy i
actually started developing a good
relationship because i started doing
things
for people that i cared about the way
that they wanted to receive it
and uh i always think about regrets
right so it's like
let's say that one day i feel
comfortable saying i love you to my mom
i feel really comfortable with it but
it's in our last 10 years of our life
i'm like
damn i wish i would have said i love you
a little more while she was around
and i don't want to live with that i
think the thing i think the fear of
regret scares me the most
i can't i can't live a regretful life
because if i live with regret it's going
to eat me up
forever that's why there's certain
things that people like oh you should do
this i'm like
yours should do for me it's not
something that i feel like if i did i
would regret
right be like oh why don't you go out
and be the biggest asian actor i don't
care about acting enough to do that
so that might be your biggest regret
because you look at opportunities that i
have
you're like oh you met with abc cbs
you're doing all these auditions you
should pursue it even more
but that's what you want from me yeah i
never said i wanted that yeah
so who really cares yeah you know so
like i just can't
i feel in that same type of way i need
to feel that conviction
to do something simply also just because
i don't want to regret not doing
something when i could have
because what if one i don't know let's
say your mom passes away the next day
and all she wanted is i love you and you
never said it what's weird is that like
i know she knows yeah like
she'll still die not she won't die being
like i wonder if frieza actually
like she knows she knows yeah this
podcast is brought to you by i
p vanish how many times do i have to
tell you lovely people out there you
need to protect your internet privacy
now
and you need to do it with ipvanish i've
been using ipvanish to make sure that
nobody's snooping around my personal
information ipvanish my friends is a
virtual private network a vpn for short
a vpn is an important tool that helps
you safely browse
the internet you can use a vpn on your
computers tablets phones and even things
like your fire stick when you're
streaming media when you use a vpn
all your data is encrypted what you're
reading what you're searching what
you're watching whatever it is you're
doing nobody's
business my friends get the hell off my
internet
so go to ipvanish.com brain claim your
65
savings their annual plan is just 44.99
for just the first year
with our exclusive discount this is the
time to sign up with our discount and
their current promotion you can get a
vpn for 65
off their usual offering ipvanish is the
best of the best even rated 4.7 out of 5
on trustpilot and that's with more than
six thousand reviews
remember it's ipvanish.combrain
to get the deal and start protecting
yourself on
line is she a words of affirmation
person such a words of affirmation
person she's so like
opposite of me high energy like oh like
she she's like my boyfriend's like my
ex-boyfriend she's like i can't
you know you never say i love you you
don't call me enough
you don't text me more meanwhile she
texts me like photos of herself every
day
like photos of like her food random
videos of like elephants and i'm like
what the [ __ ] why do they always like
they're the most random
videos on the planet she spends like
100 of her time on youtube watching like
random [ __ ]
and like she sends me like 10 links a
day i'm like i'm sorry
but like it's my turn to be the busy
working one now yeah yeah
like you you spent all your life being
the busy working one and like didn't
have time okay well it's my turn
i gotta work yeah cut the [ __ ] out yeah
i mean like i i
me and my mom are still close though
like i i end up telling you everything
you know like
i i'm not this type to talk to my
parents every single day like i need
space i'm very
independent of them i mean you're
because wait how involved was your dad
in your life growing up then
he was always there but not there like
the quintessential like
there but not emotionally there
physically there but
absent oh really what what was he doing
though just working just working or like
drinking
ah you that's the cro that's the korean
dad dude yeah yeah yeah
so he was just out it's weird because
like i you know what's weird about a lot
of those parents
when i when i hear about those stories
they they kind of have this
they they kind of chastise their
children about not being around enough
when they were very absentee themselves
as parents which is always odd for me
right they're like well you know you
should do this because
i'm your parent it's like but bro where
were you dude yeah they have this idea
of loyalty
and you know kind of they want to
receive this x amount of love
and appreciation but nothing things are
even love is very transactional
right it's like the idea of saying that
i'm a good parent oh i'm
like you're a parent just because you
gave birth to me no you're
technically my father or mother figure
but it doesn't mean that you're a parent
that kind of stuff comes with a certain
amount of responsibilities that you
fulfilled
a lot of asian parents sometimes forget
they kind of provide
here and there but they also forget
about the other part that they need to
serve in order to be
a complete parent my dad actually has no
expectation of that like he
is just grateful for whatever i give him
in terms of time
resources like money like before coming
to l.a i gave him like a fat check too
like that's my way of showing love
because he's still my dad yeah
you know like i i want to make sure he's
taken care of
because he's not like you know i i feel
like i'm i definitely make more money
than him right now
like i'm living a better lifestyle so
like it makes me feel guilty i'm just
like
to relieve my own girl i'm just like
here's a big check whatever
yeah yeah yeah you know but but even
that
to him i even though he doesn't like
express it in words and he will never
like i still we get each other at some
sort of like
like strong internal emotional
wavelength
where i know what he's thinking is like
i don't deserve this
but thank you like yeah i i don't
deserve it but thank you like
that's the vibe i get that's really nice
yeah but he he never
like puts pressure on me like i'm still
your dad like
you got to call me and see me more like
he never does that
he lets me just come to him he doesn't
like i'll take what i could get yeah
just be sweet to you hold on one sec
oh god i would hate for this
yeah when my my parents are a little
different because my mom likes to
openly threaten to kill me any any
chance that she [ __ ] gets dude
i just got a death threat the other day
and it's just like oh my mom still has
the [ __ ] fire in her
dude this woman [ __ ] pissed me off
this lady called me
maybe 12 times in the morning 12 times
in the [ __ ] morning right
when somebody who is 69 years old 69 68
years old
calls me 12 times my dad died that's
what i'm thinking
i'm like somebody died they got robbed
there was some asian hate [ __ ] my mom
[ __ ] got socked in the face
something i'm freaking the [ __ ] out call
my mom
back and my dad picks up i'm like dad
what's going on he goes
you you you like ruined my business and
i'm like what what did i do what are you
talking about
he goes on one of the podcasts that you
did you talked about one of um
our longtime customers and i'm like what
do you mean
and so on on this podcast with uh with
his with this buddy comic of mine i
talked about this dude
who uh used to uh have a beauty
a salon next to my parents store but i
was saying dope [ __ ] about him
right but they literally woke me up at 7
a.m in the morning
so i'm frantic i'm freaking the [ __ ] out
i'm like what happened he's like i saw
him today he looked so mad
he looked pissed off like he definitely
heard you said with stuff about you said
him on the podcast
and like you know he's been a good
customer for years so i need you to take
that down
oh freaking out so i call my boy up and
i'm like hey man like can you take the
podcast down like my parents are
freaking out like
apparently i said something really bad
he goes yeah whatever no problem and i
hate taking back [ __ ] that i put up
because it's what i said i need to
commit to it i either own up to it or
not
whatever so i'm waking up and then all
of a sudden
like i'm trying to collect my mind
together i'm like wait hold on a second
i call my my dad back i'm like hey what
exactly did he say he goes
he didn't say anything i just saw him he
was in a bad mood
my [ __ ] blood pressure so you don't
even know
he didn't know he saw his face in the
morning no i was like he didn't say
anything he goes oh but i know he was
acting weird i was like
i literally said don't you ever [ __ ]
call me about [ __ ] like this ever again
right and he's like what what he goes he
i was like did he say something or not
yeah he goes no i just know he was in a
bad mood
i was like so you heard the podcast and
you heard his name do you know what i
said about him
he was no i was like i was saying he was
so good to us what the [ __ ] are you
talking about
yeah and he was like oh oh oh i was like
you
literally woke me up and i thought you
died you stupid stupid man
don't you [ __ ] call me about this
[ __ ] ever again like do i ever call you
about your work
what is wrong with you right and he was
like well i know he's in the bedroom i
was like cool i'll call him up
call him up he's like what's up how you
doing i'm like tony like did you did you
hear this podcast
you guys are in like a phone call yeah
you know what's up i said what's up bro
like what's going on he's like
nah man it's all good i'm like mother
[ __ ]
like stressed me out because i felt like
i did something where i ruined their
business yeah you know
and i'm like dude that was the first
thing out of his mouth gonna be like
you've ruined our business
yeah i was like dude when i go to when i
go back home i'm gonna punch your ankles
dude
i'm gonna suck up them ankles dude in
the kneecaps
that's how involved my parents my
parents are so hyper involved in my life
it's
unreal i can't do that i can't my mom
too my mom sometimes she's like hey good
you know youtube
should do this and i'm like what the
[ __ ] you just say to me right now
don't [ __ ] tell you guys you should
go back to your old videos where you
yell
and you yell at people i like those and
i'm like that's what's gonna make you
famous again and i'm like i will [ __ ]
kill you right now
this woman just called me washed up i
was like [ __ ] listen i know this
all right like yeah what i what i love
about my parents though
like they are just so supportive of
whatever i do even before like the
youtube and stuff like no matter what
decision i made
as long as you're happy you don't even
my mom verbatim would be like you don't
need to be a straight a student just get
like maybe bees like just at least like
do
somewhat well and like just be happy hey
that means your mom thinks you're stupid
no no no my mom she was like i didn't do
well in school
i have no right yeah no but she both my
parents though like always prioritize
like
whether i was happy or not if you're
happy that's all i care about
you know and i think that's rare for
korean parents
your mom's just like hey have you heard
of uh only pants
honestly if i started that she would
still be supportive she
if she's like ride or die hey so uh
freezer park will now be starting in
only fans
i hear how much people make making uh
i'll tell you this what pics
if i had a sweet-ass [ __ ] i'd be and i
was fine
yo you best believe i'm putting up only
fans immediately dude
you may not see too much but i
definitely tease that [ __ ] every now
and then dude
these girls on only fans [ __ ] bank
it's unreal and they're banking off of
just dudes
that just genuinely want to see a little
puss puss that's like insane though
that's the power of women that's the
trade-off for your guys's periods like
you guys have periods
but you have this insane control over
horny men
they will do literally anything just to
just just to be noticed by you
god damn because i don't know i don't
know any woman that does that
any like confident strong that'll do
that to a guy
like i just wish this guy would just
notice me unless they're like very
famous and they have a lot of money
or some [ __ ] like that right yeah no
because i don't know i don't know like a
guy a girl that looks at a dude and be
like
no confident girl insecure girls yeah
for sure hundred percent do you know
like some girls like that
who will be like i just want them to
notice me yeah insecure girls yeah
oh really yeah maybe i just know some
strong [ __ ] i don't know any girls i
think you are surrounded by very strong
women because i don't know any girl like
that i don't think
but but you don't have the tolerance for
like weak-minded people
yeah they also don't like me either yeah
because you're you they don't like the
truth
yeah they don't like me much either it's
like it's hard for me to
kind of you know what is my mom's very
strong yeah she's very opinionated she
says what she wants
my mom too yeah yeah she tells me to go
kill myself every day
and she says i love you at the end you
know like i'm not i'm not used to
like women who don't it's not like they
don't know what they want
but i don't like women who are looking
for like a knight in shining armor
like i like women who kind of know what
they want in the sense of like they know
who they are
right even if they're lost they know
that they're lost right right right yeah
when when or even guys that are like
this just people in general yeah
the same like it's people who are
self-aware yeah
that's why some people like i was i was
talking to mariel about this right she
she met some of my uh
not so uh well-kept friends they're a
little uh ghetto
right and my and she was asking me like
oh why do you like those guys she goes i
don't like those guys
i was like i like them because i know
who they are
0 to 100 night and day 24 7. they are
these people
i know how they move i know how they're
going to act and i know that they're
[ __ ] loyal
if i was stranded somewhere and i hit
them up it's like yo
i need you to be here this guy would be
like there in a hot second
and i do the same for him yeah how he
behaves in terms of how he speaks
a little you know a little sus yeah
right he might use the n word a little
too much he might
he might uh be a little thuggish here
and there yeah but i know he's
superficial though
yeah yeah at the end of the day i know
who he is and i can see him for face
value right and i was like these are
the type of bonds that i make these are
confident human beings they might not be
the textbook version of what people
consider as
you know socially intelligent or
whatever but they're good
[ __ ] people right they make me laugh
and i know for a fact they'll never stab
me in the back right and that's
important when i see people who don't
have these qualities where they're
unsure about everything
and we talked about this earlier too and
i see this quality in people pleasers
people pleaders are the people that i
dislike the most and the reason why
is because you don't know who you are
i'll never know who you are right
same i can't trust you yeah who are you
going to be today you're going to be
different from tomorrow yeah you might
say the nicest [ __ ] to me now
but when and i think that we have a
genuine relationship
somebody talks [ __ ] about me you'll be
like yeah he is like that yeah you won't
be like
hey i know him he's cool yeah you know
like you don't have enough like footing
to stand your ground
as a people pleasing person you know
like so
there's no loyalty there you're always
just doing whatever people want to hear
what other people want to do like
there's there's no loyalty there
i had to talk to like uh she's she's
like a tong
right yeah and one of her worst habits
was that she connects through people by
talking [ __ ] about other people
and people bond over hate the more than
they do about
commonality of things that they like
this is a human trait you could read up
about this [ __ ]
that's just how it is and i see a lot of
that [ __ ] in myself too right
we could talk about something that we
hate way more than we can't talk about
something that we like
that's just how human beings are yeah
when she does that all that stuff
catches up though
yeah people hear about this [ __ ] and so
they're like oh well
why don't people like me it's because
you say one thing about one person
somebody will talk [ __ ] and then you'll
go ahead and join in on the fun
then you'll go back the next day hang
out with them two-faced
yeah it's two-faced [ __ ] i understand
where it's like somebody will say
something but you'll just hear them out
like okay i understand that that sucks
that happened to you but when you're
joining in the fun and
beating down on this person that's
supposed to be your really close friend
yeah that's different
yeah because not everybody's gonna be
confrontational like i've been in
situations where
friends have just complaining about
people i care about
and i'm just like hey i'm sorry that's
the experience that you have yeah
i'm like i could see that yeah yeah but
i won't be like yeah [ __ ] them
i feel like this is kind of like a hood
mentality like lower class mentality
like
like if you're two-faced like you're
exiled
yeah you know like two-faced people like
you're cancelled
back then like that's like the worst
thing you could be oh this this person's
two-faced like
that was like the biggest like
uh diss to ever hear that was like it
just meant like
no one [ __ ] with you if you're too
faced so i feel like
that used to be a really big thing for
me growing up when i was younger i was
always like i'm not too fit i'm gonna be
real
so i was trying to be as real as
possible your shoes are wet yeah your
essentially over exaggerated yes but
that's ex
that's essentially how it kind of was
and then i didn't understand that i was
being like
too brash with a lot of people yes
that's something i had to learn the hard
way where like sometimes my girlfriends
even
didn't even want to like hang out with
me anymore or like talk to me or open up
to me about certain [ __ ] because i was
too like brutally honest and like i'm
just like nah like you
you [ __ ] up like you you did this like
that's not what
no one's asking for my commentary you
know
like they just want to be heard and
listened to
but so when keeping it in the time yeah
it's like when you keep it like
there's a fine line between like being
keeping it real being like
you know real versus like being rude
yeah and
that's something i had to learn the hard
way growing up um but
it definitely came from like my queen's
upbringing too
yeah because if you were called to face
like that was like [ __ ] like you're just
cancelled in the friend group
yeah yeah yeah i it's i learned to white
lie now
i've learned so mariel had a problem
with me about this because i'm
to that to the extreme right i've gotten
so much better than the last six years
like now i have opinions about people
but or like certain things but then i
express it when it's necessary
not all the time yeah right but even
then some people still don't like it so
it's like
i can't help them at that point right
now i'm just like that's why i always
tell people like when some some people
who say like oh i'm real as [ __ ] it's
like no you're actually kind of a dick
yeah like you place your opinions on
things that your opinion doesn't need to
be placed on right
like it could be like somebody else's
joy and you have to let them know that
their joy is wack it's right
why couldn't you just let that pass yeah
like just let it go no one's asking just
like
bite your tongue and that's it yeah it's
like you could feel that way that's a
hundred percent fine but you didn't have
to bring that person down because you
told yourself
you're keeping it real when really
you're just a real [ __ ] house yeah
yeah and i had to learn that [ __ ] too
it's like uh kind of reserved it's like
why did you even say that it's just
because that's just how it was growing
up
everybody had to keep that face and if
you're two faces [ __ ] people heard about
that [ __ ]
i was from a small town too so people
hear that stuff
nobody likes somebody who could backstab
you right and even now there's people
who are acquaintances who
you know albeit like we'll kick it will
drink whatever but they're never going
to be in my inner circle
right because they have those habits
right that's how they grew up that's how
their
people connect and click with because
word gets around a lot of la people are
like that
i know i think it is you know a lot of
people and these are these aren't even
la natives they're like people
who come here to la you know like me
well i mean it's it's it's weird because
i've definitely dealt with that [ __ ]
right
and i even saw it recently too oh not
right which was like six or seven months
ago
but one of my friends actually hit me up
because i was kicking it with somebody
that
they don't really like but they were
visiting in town and so i
you know they hit me up i don't have a
problem with them this person every time
we talk they just you know talk [ __ ]
about this person because they had a
really bad business dealing that went on
back in the day
i heard both their stories they're both
[ __ ] dumb as [ __ ] they just
they were both stupid right so when he
was
here he was like venting to me about
this dude
i'm talking all this [ __ ] and i'm like
hey that sucks man like oh i'm sorry
that's what happened that's what they
did to you blah blah blah and i've heard
the story and he's just like kind of
delving into it in more detail and all i
said was oh that sucks man hey yes i get
that that's what they did to you
hey that's [ __ ] up man i'm sorry man
right so
and he twisted it back and when they
bent up or whatever whatnot they weren't
passing at a bar
somewhere back at home and this
[ __ ] calls me up he's like yo he
says that you were talking [ __ ] about me
too it was like he came up he said like
you agree with him i was like bro
first of all number one don't talk to me
like that number two
it's like you could have just asked me
these are people who are just
bored hey they're born in the [ __ ]
moment yeah they're looking for drama
they're looking for something to be mad
about
yeah all i said was all i said to him
was hey if that's what happened that
[ __ ] sucks
that doesn't mean i agree with him that
equals i don't care exactly
i don't give a [ __ ] think what you want
i do not care
do not involve me exactly i'm like hey
that sucks
oh that's real bad that's that's all i
said sorry that happened
yeah that's that's how i deal with stuff
now right or i'll talk about stuff
you don't have time yeah and then i know
how to connect i'll be like oh man like
i had something that happened to me if
that happened to me like that i'd be
pissed too
i'm not giving a commentary about what
happened to you i'm talking about the
situation and how it sucks
but they hear that as oh you so you
agree with me this person's [ __ ] i'm
like nah i didn't say that
i don't know your situation like that
nor do i really give a [ __ ]
there's a certain point in your life
where your own problems don't bother me
because i got my own [ __ ] to deal with
right
like that's what people don't understand
like especially now you're getting a
little older you could probably really
see it now it's like
yo i got all this [ __ ] i gotta deal with
you could talk to me about your problems
but i can't help you
you know i'm only here to listen that's
it you know yeah cause you know you see
it now like i'm telling you man
getting older is like a blessing because
then you start to not [ __ ] with other
people's [ __ ] do you see it well
since you mentioned like now that you're
getting older do you see like
me getting older yes really yeah oh i
hate that
but it's you getting older in a better
way though yeah yeah i'm maturing
uh i i'm seeing more you've realized
more [ __ ]
as kendall jenner would say i realized
whatever the quote was she was like i
realized
that i realized that i realized or
something
no like i see you getting older in the
sense of you kind of managing your own
emotions a little better
you also know where to spend your time
more properly and then you're also
knowing how to like assess how you feel
a lot right because before when you were
younger like there was
chaos and chaos used to affect you in
the worst way possible i think
i think it like jumbled your thoughts
your opinions your moves now when you're
in this chaos now you think about why do
i feel this way
and that's an adult thing to do now it's
not shit's [ __ ] happening i hate
feeling this way it's shit's happening
why i hate feeling this way
those are two different things adding
that why into your life
helps you evolve if you learn how to
deal with it right because
remember you said to me like when i i
asked you what is your why why do you do
these things
by the way david and i and he was in new
york and
we were just like at a bar having drinks
and like we just had this intense
conversation at one of like the lowest
periods of my life
post-breakup i didn't know what the hell
i was doing
like i was just lost in the sauce
a lot of sauce by the way i was like
what is your why
what's your why i don't know
i don't [ __ ] know what my wife is
um but then like that question and i was
telling david earlier like it really
[ __ ] me up for a while because i was
like
what is my why i was having like a legit
existential crisis after you left new
york i was like what am i living life
for um and i didn't find out the answer
right away
but yeah eventually it just like
as i developed a little bit more
self-awareness
and just reflected a little bit more
just like by living through life
my why in life going back to our point
earlier in our conversation earlier is
just to be
comfortable i don't need to be a
millionaire i don't need to like drive
fancy cars have like the biggest house
in the world i just want to be
financially free
and do things by choice and not out of
obligation
it's very good so that is my why in life
and that is why i do what i do that is
why i do youtube that is my small
business
that is the only way i know how i've
always created like you said back when i
was like 19 i was always creating that
was just for fun
um i have some talent in it i always had
an eye for it
you have a very good eye for it so yeah
it's like shocking because i look at
your stuff i'm like that's pretty
[ __ ] good
like damn and uh
i mean that's my what that's why i quit
nine to five live i hate working for
people i hate the fact that i'm making
money for other people with a [ __ ]
salary
youtube is like the only feasible
way currently that i know how to work
for myself so that is my current goal
i don't want to end that youtube i want
to like potentially do other things i
don't know what that
is but that's okay yeah what's that one
step at a time
so i'm saying like we i had my buddy uh
malik kanye and he was talking about
goal setting right and goals are very
important because it allows
you otherwise you're aimless yeah you
start doing [ __ ] for just to do [ __ ]
yeah
you know i'm kind of at that point now
where i'm just doing [ __ ] just do [ __ ]
but my why was very strong before you
know now it's like i've achieved a lot
and i'm
taking the time to really just enjoy
life right i don't know how long it's
going to last but
pandemic was kind of a blessing for me
because pandemic happened and i'm like
you know what
until pandemic's over i'm gonna just
[ __ ] be a retired man for a little
bit yeah
i'm gonna enjoy this time i'm gonna go
out as you can see as she said i look
golden and crispy right now
i was like you look so golden crispy she
made it
like lechon like [ __ ] pork belly
but you know this is the important stuff
to me it's like
i also figured out too this this idea of
gaining an x amount of wealth and
getting that first before i get to live
life is stupid to me right
i want to live life as i do it together
right yeah i could probably make more if
i cut everybody out
sit here grind every day think about the
next hot video next hot topic yeah but
for what
for what yeah like i'm not going to give
up my time you know hanging out with my
friends
biking exploring new foods going to the
beach because when i'm 50 years old and
i get to do it for the next 30 40 years
of my life who knows
and by the way when you're 50 it's like
the best parts will be between your 50
to 60.
so it's like i think what i'm gonna do
is enjoy it
now while i'm young and still be able to
continue to try to grow my wealth
incrementally right i'm not starving
uh i have a roof over my head i have
money and then some
because of how hard i work the
businesses that i'm opening up with my
friends
this is okay i won't be a gary vee but
i'll be comfortable
and i'll get to live this life so
everybody else who's grinding 24 7 you
love that life
that's good for you yeah for me i want
to enjoy every [ __ ] moment i have
especially before i have a kid like
listen kids change up your life
right now even my friends who have kids
they're like oh i can't wait to do
something so i could just
have a break i was swinging
on a chair swing yesterday for three
hours
he has this like like little disc
of a swing in his front yard which i
casually just laid on as soon as i got
here
but he's like i'm just casually
answering emails on my sleeve and i'm
like
what a great life to have
but to be fair like you like what you
did
all the years prior led up to this
moment that you can do that you know and
if i didn't have this moment in pandemic
where i was like hey bro
chill the [ __ ] out yeah i wouldn't i
wouldn't have been able to do this right
i wouldn't have been able to sit back
and kind of like
hey you know what i'm gonna go for a
[ __ ] 30 mile bike ride today
because i want to yeah and i was telling
you earlier pandemic the pandemic was
the best thing that ever happened to me
i know
like you know i'm so sorry for like
everyone that
lost family members or like you know had
been through
[ __ ] through the pandemic because it
[ __ ] sucks yeah
but on the other side the flip side it's
the most like revolutionary time in my
life where
i don't think if if it weren't for covet
i would not have moved to ellie this
soon
you know like i wouldn't have
like basically 2x my salary yeah you
know i wouldn't have taken matters into
my own hands
because of the pandemic i had more time
to
really reflect and think about what i
want to do i had more time to also
execute
yeah what i wanted to do yeah i mean
there's people who have
there's there was two things that
happened either people got wrecked or
they [ __ ] came up during this
pandemic
right a lot of people got wrecked i mean
even a lot of our businesses too
they they took a hit you know but we
survived it and we're doing well
but it took that that ability to not
want to lose that hustling mentality to
be like hey we got to figure out a way
and we're going to make this happen
yeah and the people who did take that
part on and you know
even for some people who do take that
part it didn't work out but
the people who did it turned out really
well for them it allowed
it was this weird moment where everybody
incl muriel and i talked about this our
relationships suffered really hard
because
we had to take a hard look at ourselves
are we happy what's going on am i okay
with the way that we treat each
other and it turned out we weren't and
then you know she talked about on the
podcast where she had to go through
therapy
uh and then i had to figure out that i
didn't want to be in this type of
relationship
and it fixed us if pandemic didn't
happen we would have kept sweeping our
issues
over and over and over i have a friend
of mine who talked to me recently about
meeting up with
an ex-girlfriend and they had a
very terrible relationship it was not
good at all
and it got to the point where you know
this person hated
the other person hated them to death and
the other person didn't even [ __ ]
know why
they're like why like i thought you know
we can't how come we can't be friends
after our breakup like we've had so many
good memories
but but in this person's mind he was
telling himself like
did you not know how you treated me like
he
she was a nightmare so
the other person couldn't see what the
[ __ ] the problem was
like why can't we just be friends and it
took pandemic to realize and assess all
the relationships that this person had
how they were treating other people how
they speak because
they had to sit in a room by themselves
and face themselves every day all right
no distractions no going out to eat no
kicking it all they had were their
thoughts
and this mirror who am i why do i do
this why are my relationships so bad why
do people think i'm a [ __ ] why do
people think i'm an [ __ ]
yeah and lo and behold they're like
i'm a [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] i love
that
i love i love what this pandemic has
done to
a lot of people and i've definitely seen
a lot of people tap into their creative
sides and like
muster up the courage to even pursue
that so i'm like that is dope
that's [ __ ] awesome like and they met
up this person met up with the other
person
and apologized said hey i want to make
amends
but it's like even if we can't be
friends i still have to apologize for
the way that i behaved
and like i just can't stand the fact
that you
hate me because i can't understand why
you hate me what was that like solitary
confinement for this person like
like she just had to like just all the
time like reflect and realize what she
did wrong
yeah uh it's like it's to the point
where this person just had to like
i mean paranoid because of pen because
of like the the coronavirus
so you know when you don't have to hang
out with somebody
especially when a virus is involved you
ain't got to hang out with them you'll
do anything you can not
hang out and that's the reason it's like
hey why can't you hang out ah you know
the virus
yeah you know happened a lot to this
person yeah and like oh [ __ ] but they're
hanging out with other
people i wonder why it's because every
time we're around it's like oh i must be
the problem
yeah so what's wrong with me exactly
when you start like okay gotcha
yeah and so you know you have to face
you have to face these ideas
all the [ __ ] time yeah and even for
me too there was like stuff that i
think about that i do a lot one what the
biggest thing that i found out was that
i have
anxiety problems like a [ __ ] i
had no [ __ ] idea
yeah i was like oh [ __ ] and i i just
thought i was a little [ __ ]
you know i'm like no this is so [ __ ]
anxiety pop some cbd and i'm like hey
you're boy good
yeah we're chilling i'm like hey i'm
good
you know i smoke a cbd joint every night
and i'm like i'm chilling
i'm like oh what was i worrying about
yeah it's crazy dude i told this
[ __ ] story where recently i was on a
plane and then my anxiety like
let me tell you my mind is already
shining the highest right and it was
with my buddy uh
his name is jason cheney he's a stand-up
comic and uh i basically told him i was
on a plane
and i i was in first class at hawaiian
air
and during this time they're passing out
uh ipads for people to watch movies
i fell asleep during the time they were
passing out ipads my anxiety kicked in
i couldn't ask for the ipad dude that's
something that i would do
it's like you're afraid of like customer
service yeah yeah
like even when i go like have to hop on
the phone with customer service i'm like
okay okay okay yeah okay we got it okay
this is what you're going to say like
this is exactly what you're going to do
it's gonna be great
hello yeah one of the biggest signs of
anxiety is over preparation
oh that's me yeah so like for me like i
found out when my buddy nick's like yo
why do you know everything about
everything dude and i'm like i don't
know
like we'll be walking around i'm like oh
this tree right here is this
like why do you know that is because we
over prepare because we don't want to be
caught off guard
there is also something i forgot who
pointed this out to me because i'm the
type of person who watches the same
movies over and over again
they say people with anxiety don't like
to try new movies because if it
disappoints them then it's like oh [ __ ]
it's like oh [ __ ] it's like you also
don't know what you're getting yourself
into
yeah it's it's just weird weird thing
right i didn't know how severe it was
like i'm literally hawaiian air
and then i'm like my phone is dying by
the way i need an ipad yeah
but i don't want people to know what to
ask i don't want to ask because i don't
want people
i was like i know i've been in first
class before so i know how first class
people be
like that doesn't make any sense just
ask for a [ __ ] ipad but i'm here with
this dying [ __ ] phone just like
i definitely got better about it though
like when i was younger my mom used to
have to
force me to like really like
if i was at like uh like a store or
something and i wanted something
she was like go ask yourself because i
was so shy i was like
terrified of talking to people
especially adults
she's like no go because i i can't like
you have a problem yeah she's like you
have a problem you gotta practice
my dad hated that about you yeah he used
to beat my [ __ ] ass well you too
yeah so like i couldn't order mcdonald's
yeah same like something i like burger
king like should you like go ask for
ketchup
yes that's what my parents would do it's
like you want the you want the number
one you want the the big mac or the
whopper go ahead
i'm like oh i can't do it it's like i'll
[ __ ] kill you
go order and i'm or i'm like and i get
the food and he's like what the [ __ ] is
your problem just do it you know
i didn't know that was anxiety i just
thought i was weak i thought i was just
shy
yeah is that a shot it's just we're over
analyzing something that's not a big
deal
that people don't give a [ __ ] about
right and we think that they give a [ __ ]
yeah but just which my friend said too
he's like you're the most confident
person that deals with anxiety
because i've literally seen you tell
people [ __ ] off that's people that's me
too
why are we like this
why the [ __ ] are you like how weird is
that though it's
so weird because like i was painfully
shy throughout high school too
and it's just like it was and now that i
look back at it
because i was a psychology major so like
and now i can look in hindsight like
what exactly that was
i was just so afraid of what people
would say or think about me if i like
did the wrong thing or did the wrong
move and i'm just like analyzing myself
i'm like where where is the where does
that come from
like why do you do this but like now
we're kind of just like hey
yeah like [ __ ] you yeah i was like hey
give me a drink i'll be fine
you know or i'll i just like that's i
think that's why i like drinking
mmm it gets rid of that social anxiety
the anxiety is gone
yeah every time i do a one-on-one with
you i'm comfortable because like i've
known you for such a long time but
if i do a one-on-one meeting with
someone new
i'm always like over preparing in my
head i'm like oh my god if it's awkward
like
make sure you have these questions to
ask like yeah it's crazy
like i still am like that today but like
with alcohol on my eyes fine like
once i have a few drinks in i'm cool but
i think that's why i like drinking
because it like
it uh lowers all the barriers yeah it
kind of like numbs you out to things
right you just you don't overthink as
much yeah you don't overthink you just
do
yeah like now too like it's a part of
the things that i realized recently
that i do because of my anxiety it used
to be like over preparation
now i ignore things to the best it's
like i don't want to think about it yeah
and then i just go and do it and i'm
like you know what
if i start over prepping then it's going
to be an anxiety and do situation
where i during the preparation i'm
[ __ ] anxious as [ __ ]
now i'm just like let's just go do it
and see what happens and i just ignore
it until the day of
and i do that a lot where i don't know
where things are happening i'm like hey
remember you have this thing i'm like
oh [ __ ] that's right i do like a defense
mechanism it is but it's bad because i'm
a business person i shouldn't be doing
that yeah
that's why i need a [ __ ] assistant
yeah yeah it's kind of nuts
i am i am very i've never been diagnosed
with anxiety but like i know that i have
like high anxiety
oh 100 yeah there's people who deal with
it
um i now deal with it a lot also because
i'm very stubborn
i now force myself in situations where i
just don't
like the fact that this thing controls
my life
i hate it i hate it so [ __ ] much and
i'm like you little [ __ ] you better
[ __ ] just
ask for the extra mustard [ __ ] just do
it yeah
do you have mustard
yellow dog what's wrong with you bro and
then my brother has that [ __ ]
too and he has it worse than me and it
takes the [ __ ] out of me like i hate
that [ __ ] like we'll be ordering food
like just [ __ ] ask for what you want
like that kind of yeah dude that should
pin me off so bad like we'll be going to
a restaurant he goes hey just order me
whatever i'm like
no you order what you want and what do
you like he goes i don't know
i think my roommate my most recent
roommate john he saw it firsthand how
much anxiety i have because like most
people who
are just friends with me they don't see
that side of me they don't see my
day-to-day
so everyone when i tell them i have like
kind of lightweight like i have anxiety
they're like you huh you're like so
talkative like you're so like out there
and confident whatever blah blah blah
i'm like no yeah and then john after
living with me he'd be like yeah you're
just like afraid little like dog
like like just like you're like
you need to like overthink everything
before you actually do
a hundred percent which i'm like yeah
that's that's for you yeah now
i just faked the [ __ ] funk now dude
i'm just like i do stuff and let me tell
you something
it's it's weird because
yeah i'm a very confusing person like i
could tell something yeah
tell somebody to [ __ ] off i don't give a
[ __ ] about what you think blah blah blah
but if it comes to ordering a hamburger
i'm like
oh my word oh they forgot the awareness
but i tell them
i was like okay if i order this burger
what if i get the one that i don't like
do i have to order a [ __ ] another one
yeah i'm gonna have to come back here
all over again no i think that
she's probably gonna watch this yeah and
i sit there i'm like hey how about you
go order first i'll see if you like it
then i'll see if i'll get it after and
then if i do like it then maybe i will
another thing uh year after year after
year in parent teacher conference the
biggest feedback that all my teachers
had
my mom would tell me is that frieza is
afraid to have the wrong answer
oh yeah that's another sign of anxiety
she's afraid of
max yeah that's uh she's afraid to be
wrong um
that that that that is actually me when
school was like that too
i hated getting picked on because i was
afraid i had them yeah even when i knew
the answer yeah yeah same i would never
raise my hand even if i knew the answer
in case the point five percent chance
that i was wrong
i didn't i didn't want to like risk it
let me tell you sometimes too there was
these moments where i'm like hey you
know what today
david you know that answer you gonna say
it raise my hand like all week and [ __ ]
and my the answer is george washington
they're like nice try but it's not and
then i go you [ __ ]
yeah you [ __ ] you thought you knew it
you stupid [ __ ]
yeah i'm just sitting there just boiling
on the inside like oh my god is that
is that like low-key like narcissism
like what do you care so much about what
like
people think yeah i think another form
of it
i guess maybe it could be which is weird
because like that's also the complicated
thing too because
i don't give a [ __ ] about what i look
like dressed like whatever but then when
it comes to having a wrong answer i'm
like yeah you don't want to look stupid
yeah how weird is that yeah man all
types are [ __ ] up dude
the same hey do we have like yo we out
here because there's a
[ __ ] therapist that can help us out
maybe with our issues or something
i'm looking for a therapist yo better
help you know better health does help
though
maybe this is what i should bring up
next time hey how come i'm afraid of
being wrong
yeah you know no yeah yeah yeah which is
weird that's such a weird thing
huh that was the feedback that every
teacher had for me no
like there was no relationship between
my first grade teacher second grade
teacher
it's not like they're talking [ __ ] years
later being like freaky yeah remember
that girl frieza like she was always
afraid of being wrong
that's never the case there's just
always the same observation from every
teacher
yeah oh [ __ ] that's like a real thing
dude recently too like i don't know why
i blanked out but i was describing
the software i had a soft serve opening
right and
this [ __ ] ate me up a little bit i i
mean i got over it really fast but
i because i told myself how dumb it is
like you made a mistake
so for some reason when people were
asking me what pendant was pendant is
like a tropical vegetable or some [ __ ]
right it's like
you see it like in uh filipino food
already what if i'm wrong
so when i was explaining it the the
flavor soft serve that we had was
pandan almond right and they were asking
me oh what's pandan but for some reason
i heard it as
oh i was like what's what's the flavor
of the soft serve and i was like oh it's
basically almond
and so i said it in a video and they're
like pendant is an almond and i'm like
what did i say i said pendant is almond
flavored
and i kept saying it over and over in
the video and i was like you [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know it's not
why did you say that wait can i tell you
something with my job
so for those of you guys that don't know
i do social media for complex my
full-time job
that sometimes is the most
anxiety-ridden position
when you have to be the consumer-facing
voice of complex
this 8.8 million following on instagram
although and then you have facebook and
twitter you have to be careful what you
say
and if you say the wrong [ __ ] like
you're just gonna get like [ __ ]
like be lit up [ __ ] on so one time
i posted like a sunset moody pig is
vibey i think yo this sunset slaps or
something
like that in the in the caption and then
everybody was like
bruh like who the [ __ ] is behind
conflict social like no one says slap
behind
a [ __ ] sunset you say slap when like
it's like a good
song or like that's [ __ ] funny i was
like oh
[ __ ] why did i say that
i'm just trying to be cool
and now i'm just like i double check
everything i write like i'm very
cautious of the new words i
use and just like uh you know what's so
funny about young people though and like
slang it's like you know slang aren't
[ __ ] real words you can make it
you can say whatever the [ __ ] you want
dude like dog here's like the biggest
like bare area [ __ ] right
for food and dog some berry people they
get so
[ __ ] like mad mad about that [ __ ]
like my buddy alex he goes yo this food
slaps he said it for me a million times
it's just like whatever
people in the comments you don't say
that for [ __ ] uh
music i'm for uh for [ __ ] food you
say that for music
what are you the king of slang [ __ ]
shut the [ __ ] up i know i've definitely
heard it like being used in other like
contexts
outside all the time yeah it is what it
is you say whatever the [ __ ] you want
who cares
[ __ ] god damn it i'm so stupid
that's why i felt about the pen then i
was like i know that is an almond i
thought the person was asking what the
flavor of the sausage
even though they weren't saying about
that's how i heard it yeah so i kept on
saying it yeah a lot of people don't
know it's almond yeah but they're like
dude david didn't even know the flavor
of soft serve i was like i
do i do know what pandan is like i just
didn't hear it right
yeah i'm just like sitting there like oh
these guys people think i'm an idiot why
are we like this
i don't know but we need therapy yeah i
need more therapy i'll talk to
talk about this with my therapist so
thank you better help for sponsoring
this video i know
my [ __ ] ass chicks are sweating dude
just thinking about the [ __ ] pandan
comment goddammit
you and your slaps well guys that wraps
up this episode of the genius brain
podcast thank you for freesia for coming
on again you might see her again just
because she'll
be all up in my neighborhood now in l.a
now yeah so frieza where can they find
you
you can find me on my socials it's
freesia park on
basically everything freesia park check
her out on the youtube she does the best
like daily lifestyle vlogs i've ever
seen
in my life's [ __ ] your [ __ ] that [ __ ]
slaps
that [ __ ] slaps it is sweet like pandan
baby hell yeah
we'll see y'all next time every
thursdays and sundays peace peace